[Music]
on this Monday night secret Chinese
police stations in the heart of New York
City two U.S citizens charged accused of
doing the bidding of the Chinese
government the ultimate purpose of this
illegal police station was not to
protect and serve but rather silence
harass
looming strike action more than 150 000
public servants set to walk off the job
tomorrow what it could mean for taxes
and passports
shooting for culture change why Canada's
minister of sports says restoring Frozen
Hockey Canada funding is no blank check
and meet the extremets
the group of Brave adventurous women
taking the plunge to push the boundaries
National with Donna Friesen good evening
and thanks for joining us we begin
tonight in the United States where the
FBI has arrested two American citizens
it alleges our Chinese agents working to
monitor harass and silence Chinese
dissidents and pro-democracy activists
the men are accused of operating a
secret police station in the middle of
New York City similar to the ones being
investigated here in Canada U.S
authorities are calling it a flagrant
violation by China of America's
sovereignty Jackson prosco has our top
story tonight the alleged Chinese
Outpost operated in the heart of
Manhattan prosecutors say it was a base
for a campaign of transnational
repression targeting pro-democracy
activists and Chinese dissidents on
American soil it is our belief that the
ultimate purpose of this illegal police
station was not to protect and serve but
rather silence harass and threaten
individuals here in the United States
two New Yorkers are now charged with
conspiring with Chinese authorities and
later deleting evidence of their
Communications the FBI alleges the men
worked at the station to locate at least
one pro-democracy activist in the U.S at
the behest of Chinese authorities these
defendants did China's bidding in secret
in a separate investigation 34 members
of China's national Police Service are
charged with running a campaign of
harassment and intimidation targeting
Chinese Nationals in the U.S online
troll Farms spread beijing's message and
attacked activists we are on to you
we know what you're doing
and we will stop it China's tactics
especially its dozens of so-called
police stations are under investigation
around the world
in Canada Spanish Civil Rights group
revealed there were three potential
outposts in the Toronto area and one in
Richmond BC while in Quebec there's an
ongoing RCMP probe into two suspected
facilities our investigations are
continuing in those matters and if we
gather enough evidence to lay the
appropriate charges we will do so
has long insisted the properties are
volunteer-run service centers that have
no connection to policing or national
security
the charges in New York suggest Western
authorities can now prove otherwise a
third complaint was unsealed Monday
alleging China also compromised the
video conferencing service zoom in an
effort to Target dissidents a zoom
executive has been accused of disrupting
meetings and of sharing information with
the Chinese government
Donna okay Jackson prosco in Washington
thanks in Canada dozens of top military
and National Security leaders plus
former politicians have signed an open
letter calling on the federal government
to spend more on National Security and
defense they say Canada's capabilities
of atrophied after years of cost-cutting
and downsizing and that this country
cannot afford to conduct business as
usual
the letter released by the conference of
Defense associations Institute is signed
by five former liberal and conservative
defense ministers nine former Chiefs of
the defense staff four former
ambassadors and a former Supreme Court
Justice it calls on Canada to radically
accelerate timelines for procurement and
to fully discharge the commitments made
to its allies and partners Canada's
defense spending last year was just 1.29
percent of GDP well below NATO's two
percent Target
the Canadian Broadcasting Corporation
says it is pausing its activity on
Twitter after the social media platform
labeled the news Outlet as
government-funded media at the urging of
federal conservative leader Pierre
paliev in a tweet the CBC said our
journalism is impartial and independent
to suggest otherwise is untrue that is
why we are pausing our activities on
Twitter CBC and Radio Canada are not
government funded they are publicly
funded through a parliamentary
appropriation that is voted on by all
members of parliament attitudes towards
many established news organizations
especially from conservative politicians
have hardened in the last decade and
accusations of fake news have become a
common political refrain an Alberta
Premier Danielle Smith has announced she
will limit reporters to just one
question no more follow-ups on the eve
of an election it's widely seen as an
attempt to avoid too much scrutiny
Heather urich's West reports
so I just have to say that we've had a
question or follow-up for years and I
don't understand why we don't have a
follow-up this time Audrey offers an
election right yeah that's why we're
sort of getting into election mode and
so we've lots of people want to change
anything a frustrated exchange between a
reporter and Alberta's Premier Friday
after a new pre-election communication
policy was announced for the next six
weeks reporters will be able to ask the
premier and leader of the United
conservative party one question and one
question alone on the last pre-election
episode of her radio call-in show on a
station owned by the parent company of
global news Smith explained the policy
shift we were going to continue doing
media availabilities we're going to
continue doing scrums we're going to
continue doing Town Halls it's just each
media Outlet we'll get one question
instead of getting two while we're in
this period of the campaign because I I
just need to make sure that we're
getting to as many people as possible
given we're heading into an election and
the Writ is yet to be dropped this is
another level of troll of the narrative
the policy comes as the UCP leader faces
accusations that she interfered in the
administration of justice by talking
with a Calgary pastor about his case in
the weeks before his criminal trial
Archer palowski is charged with Mischief
for inciting people to continue a
blockade at the Coots border crossing
last year Smith's conversation with
polowski is now the subject of an
investigation by the provincial ethics
commissioner she's not afraid to pick a
fight with the media right I think it's
a bit of strategy going into an election
that's going to be a pretty ugly it's a
strategy according to this former UCP
government Chief of Staff designed to
resonate with Smith's base and increase
opportunities for questions from
conservative friendly news outlets but
will the strategy lead to more Alberta
voter support there's just six weeks
left to find out Heather urich's West
Global News Calgary
MPS are back at work in Ottawa after a
two-week break a looming strike by
federal government employees we'll have
more on that in a moment plus inflation
that's threatening the economy and
constant questions about foreign
interference is all putting pressure on
the government our chief political
correspondent David Aiken is following
developments
statements by members declaration the
government began the Parliamentary week
with a simple Mission passed the budget
we are going to make sure that Canada's
economy is on the train to the 21st and
22nd centuries but the official
opposition had a different Mission keep
up the pressure on what it perceives as
a failing Government after eight years
of this government's soft on crime
policies Canadians don't feel safe to
walk on the streets or use public
transit the government has been trying
to censor social media platforms for
quite some time they told us that the
carbon tax would make emissions go down
well the new report out shows that for
the most recent years emissions went up
the tax goes up the emissions goes up at
a morning press conference the Prime
Minister dismissed concerns about the
path his government has taken to govern
is to choose and the choices we're
making are consistently about building
the very best future for Canadians in
every way and that includes keeping
people safe the conservatives are also
keeping up their pressure on the foreign
interference file arguing Monday for a
new parliamentary committee
investigation into the Trudeau
Foundation that's the charity that bears
the name of the prime minister's father
Pierre Elliott Trudeau the foundation's
directors resigned on mass last week and
the foundation itself has called in the
auditor general to examine the
circumstances of a failed attempt to
return a 140 thousand dollar donation
given to the foundation by an individual
who allegedly has close ties to the
government in Beijing it is becoming
clear that there was from the beginning
a concerted effort by the Xi Jinping
regime to co-opt and shape the direction
of this liberal government the
government rejects that idea and the
Prime Minister himself says he has
nothing to do with the foundation named
for his father it's been 10 years now
that I've had no director indirect
involvement with the Trudeau Foundation
that answer is not going to calm the
opposition though and as a result we
could soon be in the extra ordinary
situation where four different
parliamentary committees are each
conducting their own investigation into
foreign interference interference the
opposition alleges benefited liberals
Donna okay David Aiken and Ottawa thanks
a strike by Canada's largest public
sector Union is looming more than 155
000 Canadian Federal public servants are
set to walk off the job Wednesday if a
deal can't be reached with the federal
government the union claims there has
been little movement on its key
priorities so it's issued an ultimatum
we've already been at the table
for nearly two years
and these workers can't wait any longer
that's why we're setting a clock on this
round of bargaining
that clock is set for 9 pm Eastern
Tuesday if there's no deal they walk
turia Israel explains what the union
wants and what impact a strike would
have
toy stores are in the business of fun
but there can be little Joy when it
comes to calling the Canada Revenue
Agency so right now if you want to call
a government as a small business owner
like anyone I guess you have to be half
a day on the phone you have to have to
take a half a day off work to get to
talk to anybody that weight could get
even longer if a looming strike goes
ahead
tens of thousands of federal public
sector workers including CRA employees
are threatening to go on strike
Wednesday just a week and a half before
the deadline to file personal taxes with
service levels already being terrible
what happens then if this staff is
actually taken out for those staff
members the main point of contention is
pay the union says most of its workers
make between forty and sixty five
thousand dollars a year workers didn't
cause inflation we shouldn't have the
burden that that responsibility the
government increased its offer to a nine
percent wage hike over three years but
the public service Alliance of Canada
wants a 13 and a half percent raise over
three years we're very hopeful that
we're going to be able to resolve this
but it's at the bargaining table that
these things happen employees also want
more rights to work from home the
federal government mandated them back to
the office for two to three days a week
what is a picket line mean in 2023 the
union is striking in part for the right
to work from home but is insisting that
workers show up physically at the picket
line if they want to get strike paid if
the strike goes ahead there could be
more service disruptions and delays
things like processing immigration
applications and passports
Ottawa only recently cleared the massive
backlog it was a a little bit unnerving
that it was coming up we had to get
together soon and come out extra early
to make sure that we got the passport on
time for our trip if there is a strike
the government insists essential
services will continue and for now the
CRA has no plans to extend the May 1st
tax deadline for most Canadians Donna
all right tariya isri in Ottawa the
battle for control in Sudan coming up
dozens dead even hospitals under attack
is fighting between a paramilitary group
and the Sudanese Army intensified
an 85 year old Missouri homeowner
accused of shooting a black teenager who
rang the wrong doorbell has been charged
the teenager intended to pick up his
11-year-old twin brothers but went to
the wrong address the family's lawyer
says 16-year-old Ralph yarrow was shot
twice including once in the head and
while a boy was still on the ground the
homeowner opened fire a second time URL
is now in stable condition the homeowner
who was white has been charged with
assault in the first degree in armed
criminal action the prosecutor says
there was a racial component to the case
in Moscow an outspoken critic of
Vladimir Putin has been sentenced to 25
years after a brief trial Vladimir Kara
Mirza was found guilty on three charges
including treason for publicly
denouncing Russia's war in Ukraine as
Mike Armstrong reports Kara mirza's wife
says the sentence is meant to send a
message
Vladimir cameras that stood in the Box
as the judge read the sentence unlike
the trial which was completely closed
observers were able to follow from
another room State prosecutors had asked
for the maximum sentence they got it 25
years among those attending in person
Canada's ambassador to Russia regardless
of this verdict freedom-minded people in
this country and all over the world
recognize Vladimir karamuza as a man of
honor and conscience
the 41 year old is a former historian
and journalist turned long-time
political activist you he was charged
with treason running an undesirable
organization and spreading false
information about the Russian army
after its invasion of Ukraine in
February of 2022 the Kremlin brought in
a wartime censorship law even calling
the war a war was made illegal
it can only be referred to as a special
military operation
caramurz's lawyer says the maximum
sentence wouldn't have been handed down
if the court had followed the law her
client is a father of three with a clean
record this sentence shows that there's
so afraid of him
and they hate him so much
for his consistency for his courage now
this isn't something that had to happen
karamerza was outside Russia at the time
of the invasion he could have kept
speaking out at a distance safely
another Kremlin critic Lexi navalny had
returned to Russia a year earlier and
been arrested immediately for me it's
really heartbreaking and Nicholas tenzer
says he and others pleaded with caramoza
not to go back but dissuading him was
impossible Kara Mirza said his voice had
to be heard from home all the criticisms
we are uttering from abroad do not have
exactly the same value the sentence may
have its intended chilling effect on
Kremlin critics but the US ambassador
says it's not a sign of strength quite
the opposite the Kremlin criminalizing
criticism she says is a sign of weakness
Mike Armstrong Global News
the Canadian embassy and the capital of
Sudan along with other embassies has
been shut down for a third straight day
as the forces of rival generals battle
for control of that African nation
airstrikes and shelling intensified
today in parts of the capital and other
cities leaving millions of residents
hiding in their homes while doctors and
hospitals themselves under attack
struggle to cope with mounting
casualties the U.N Envoy to Sudan says
more than 180 people have been killed
nearly 2 000 injured since the fighting
erupted the situation is making the
humanitarian crisis in Africa's third
largest country even worse the world
fruit program says over one-third of the
population is facing acute food
insecurity and three million people are
displaced
it's being called a record drug seizure
for Italy police recovered nearly two
tons of cocaine floating off the coast
of Sicily it's worth more than 400
million euros the drugs were found
during a routine Navy surveillance
flight authorities suspect the hole was
dumped at Sea by a cargo ship with the
intention of it being recovered later by
traffickers
building back trust still ahead players
and parents respond to a reset from
Hockey Canada
[Music]
they were so close but it just wasn't in
the cards for Canada at the women's
world hockey championship they lost 6-3
to the U.S in the gold medal match their
American Rivals scoring three times in
the last four minutes just before the
puck dropped on that game the federal
government announced it is resuming
funding to Hockey Canada with conditions
funding was frozen over concerns the
organization quietly settled sexual
assault claims nithu garchow explains
what signals restoring Government
funding sends
Pocky dad player and Coach dampy Brar
and his 15 year old son know the culture
in the sport needs to change the change
has to to start and we always say from
the top uh top down we have to fix that
uh culture in the dressing rooms and uh
uh the players need to be more positive
and uh work together teamwork and like
build each other up and they're eager to
see how Hockey Canada will help set a
new example now that it claims to have
built back some trust after its
mishandling and cover-up of an alleged
sexual assault in 2018. what were your
thoughts when you heard that the funding
is going to be restored I think it's
probably in my opinion premature for the
government of Canada to reinstate
funding the federal government says the
national governing body has met the
conditions that were set out but for
some like this junior hockey team GM
it's left more questions than answers
it's still been very tight-lipped from
Hockey Canada's perspective and and
that's what concerns me still is are
things really changing you know or are
we being pressured now to give Hawk
Canada back the money because of you
know recent events that are going on
again it's the top sport in Canada
Federal sport Minister Pascal santalos
was asked why ottawa's conditions for
Hockey Canada don't include a ban on the
use of non-disclosure agreements like
the one used to cover up Hockey Canada's
settlement of the case in which a young
woman alleged eight hockey players
sexually assaulted her we are looking at
ways that we can deal with that question
not only for Hockey Canada but for all
federally funded sport organizations
we're working on it currently so we'll
come back with more answers about that
conditions include implementing
recommendations from a review and more
frequent reporting to Ottawa Hockey
Canada has yet to hire a new CEO after
electing a new nine-member board in
December it affects those programs that
rely on this type of funding and to
introduce kids and to hockey especially
at the Grassroots level if the culture
feels good in the room like the team
will also do well the Brar say the major
culture shift promised by Hockey Canada
would be the biggest game changer for
those in the minor leagues like them
nitu Garcia Global News Coquitlam BC
extreme exhilaration next the New
Brunswick women living life to the
fullest
[Music]
beautiful hiking trails are one of the
many things Canada is known for but a
group of women in New Brunswick is not
content to stick to the trails their
motto is taking life to the extreme and
for them that means plunging into icy
waterfalls no matter the season Shelly
Steves caught up with them on one of
their Adventures
their theme song kind of says it all
when it comes to Adventure these New
Brunswick women are all in we don't like
to do things plain way we like to do
things the extreme way this group of
just over 100 strong of adventurous
outdoorsy women call themselves The
extremets stripping down to their
swimsuits even in the dead of winter to
dip in one of the provinces 500
waterfalls anytime I meet new people or
you know when I've started a new job
it's like tell me something interesting
about yourself whether you are a newbie
or a veteran I'm just gonna do it and
we'll see how it goes now the girls do
have a few rules stay out of the current
never dip alone and of course learn how
to breathe slow and deep to make the
most of your plunge it's accelerating
and I'm gonna feel this Buzz for a few
hours actually
well since they brought me a suit I was
not about to wimp out with this crew all
right let's do it
oh my God extreme is indeed good way to
describe the experience as I was
instantly unable to feel my legs
but there was indeed a strong sense of
empowerment and togetherness being an
extreme
even if it only lasted a few seconds
after all life is short do it Shelly
Steve's Global News Henderson settlement
New Brunswick Love It Go Shelly that is
global national for this Monday I'm
Donna Friesen tonight's your Canada is
Courtney BC thanks for watching hope to
see you here again tomorrow bye-bye
thank you